father figures the movie that you are
currently promoting you shot that film
in your hometown yeah and I would think
that would be a dream come true because
you come back home and you're the hero
right yeah yeah I mean it's sort of a
double-edged sword that way a little bit
I notice he's a double-edged I just see
I hear I'm coming home and I'm here I
get that I bet you would think you would
but also you have to remember that that
your hometown is also where all of your
all of your high school angst and
adolescent insecurities sort of bubbled
up so when I go back I'm kind of yeah I
feel like the cool guy to my co-stars
because I'm down I know the cool
restaurants but then if we go to a cool
restaurant and like a few tables over is
the bully who gave me wedgies then I I
freeze up I just start urinating well
listen first of all how bad a freezer
now first of all where was here letting
go where's your home hands where's your
hometown Atlanta all right now why is it
that I'm getting the sense that you
weren't like the cool football star when
you were that's well I experienced in
high school so I'm shocked that you
didn't have the same one what's your
problem I'll tell you let me throw you
to two little foul bad was it when you
were growing up I had I got glasses in
the second grade oh and then I went to
the same school all the way through so I
was in like I was a nerd from second
grade on you can't that that's like a
scarlet letter you can't get out from
under that you can't reinvent yourself
and then I also had gigantic teeth which
I have grown into right right now you
mean you as if you had teeth that size
it took your body like 30 years narrow
into them exactly and did you have a
cool nickname at least when you were
growing up yeah yeah well because of
that I sort of I wouldn't say it's a
cool nickname but I sort of resembled a
certain pizza franchise mascot so what
they call Chucky Cheese because you
that's terrible that's not I was hoping
it was showbiz yeah I think we have a
picture here of you at this tender a oh
yeah yeah yeah we'll say this it's an
unfortunate time for glasses it really
lasses they didn't make a quick biggest
didn't exist no they didn't know how to
make cool glasses no right they didn't
have the technology now everybody looked
like Ted Bundy yeah they were going
snorkeling yeah yeah we're ignoring God
yes yeah we ever able to get away and
just be yourself as a kid I went to a
summer camp that were you the cool guy
there I was a cool guy
now that's where I had a counselor who
called me Edie and whereas I was Edward
all through school and Edward is also
kind of a little bit of a nerdy moniker
yeah so when I got when I got to camp
there was a counselor Donny who called
me Edie and I and that's where I sort of
felt cool right yeah really that much
that's all it took I should have gone
from Conan to Kohn I would have been
revered by people coño know so much
no not come Co is kind of cool
you